puppy where we're stepping up okay so
I'm going to do it in long form here
which is that I'm gonna use the formula
and I'm going to use it now how many
times how many applications how many
parabolas am I gonna have if I've got
six sub intervals I'm gonna have three
because it's in on - okay so I know I
start to write this out I'm gonna write
it in full form so it's gonna be an H on
I've got now my upper and lower
boundaries are still saying let's do
want to okay but what happens in between
changes right so before I write out the
rest of this let's talk about this and
is six so what is H H again I take that
distance right which is B minus a which
is one in this case and then I divide by
one of my / I / however many intervals I
have right so in this case I divided by
two because I had to stop interval now
that I've got six I'm gonna divide by
six
okay so quite small right so I'm gonna
get pretty good accuracy yeah all right
edges one on six now I have to use that
to work out what all my function values
are okay now that was super easy in this
case only had three right but what am i
function values here my values will be
I'll start at one and then I go forward
one perpendicular height right so I
guess the next one will be seven six and
then the next one will be eight six nine
six and all the way up until I get to
the last one the upper boundary okay so
that's a big gross but thankfully the
functions not
so now I'm going to start to put this
into my so I'm gonna have the first
parabola right he's made up of these
first three values yeah so I'm gonna go
F of one for lots of the next one and F
of that last one to end out my forever
okay one two and three I'm done okay now
then I can go on to the next problem
this one one two three values see it see
how I'm piecing it together so this is
going to be plus is the same
perpendicular height right there's my
eight one six doubles up one for lots of
that one and then one lot of that's the
second power and he is the third one
okay you see how I'm just taking these
values water-type so H on three of ten
on six is my first one for lots of the
middle one and wonderful off I'm done
okay so these methods so I will in a
second yeah so on this method right
obviously takes significantly longer to
write okay but if you after doing a few
of these exercises right if you're
finding that you're getting is is just
numerically wrong because you're missing
out the method okay that's a sign which
is stop using the the compressed version
the one for two for two
sorry two for one just stop using that
one and go that's actually doing it from
scratch okay to reduce the
okay so now I'm gonna start to evaluate
somewhere know this yeah h13 let's let's
factor it out so that's one and 18
yeah okay
everyone is still just one now I've got
four lights off and my function is just
take the reciprocal right so that's nice
and easy for lots of six on seven - ah -
six on eight which is 3/4 four months of
six or nine which is two-thirds sure
lots of what I'm about to hear six bun
ten which is okay yeah that looks a bit
gross right thank God for incubation but
you work it out actually I can't
remember what this fraction is okay
let's keep what this one is give you
zero point
I'm Austin is that okay is the other six
six point six nine there yeah okay great
ah now since we've got that as a decimal
come again this is a decimal as well
because because what I've started with
like I've defined the left hand side as
this song this integral right so this
integral is equal to bad but I'm not
working out the integral here I'm
working on an approximation to meet you
know I did get us once someone said hey
you know what this is approximately
equals fine but when I go from this line
to this line those odd those two equal
so shouldn't I change to an equal sign
and the answer is no I'm saying left
hand side is right hand side okay
sorry can someone give me this is
invisible thank you okay right so that's
how you approach this question right if
you like you can go straight to this
form that's fine but like I said the
more shortcuts you use the more
error-prone it is so if you're making
errors stop using the shortcuts until
you okay now I picked the same function
I think that we used to practice
trapezoidal rule on okay so let's just
take a motor to step back and appreciate
how awesome
Ravens work was right what is this area
actually equal to because we can work it
out right from one to two it's going to
be log X with those boundaries okay so
it's log 2 minus log 1 which is zero so
what's log 2 1 4 7 okay so you can see
because we did Simpsons rule right what
are getting pretty close right well how
is that that's four would you do four
decimal places not bad right but then
you look at you look at this amount of
work versus this amount of work and yeah
that's why integrations